en marzo 18 1890 menores de edad fueron
hallados sin acompañantes en la frontera
con estados unidos es la mayor cifra de
niños migrantes encontrados en esa
situación desde que las autoridades
empezaron a contabilizar los datos en
y te dejaron solo botado no había una
coma mío compartido con nadie
y este menor que ahora se encuentra ya
en un refugio para menores en territorio
estadounidense vago durante cuatro horas
en el desierto de texas antes de que la
guardia fronteriza lo encontrara es tan
sólo uno de los miles de niños que
viajan solos hacia eeuu con la intención
de entrada al país la llegada masiva se
ha convertido en un reto para el
gobierno de joe biden que trabaja para
llevarlos a casas de acogida
administración
para mantener la capacidad suficiente
para sacar a esos niños de la patrulla
fronteriza lo suficientemente rápido en
los últimos días parece que han superado
la peor etapa y cada día amarillo salen
de la custodia de la patrulla fronteriza
la cantidad de menores que viajan solos
hacia eeuu aumentó tras la llegada de
joe biden a la casa blanca y de sus
anuncios de que no reportaría menores
una postura opuesta a la de su antecesor
donald trump quien fue duramente
criticado por separar a más de 5.000
niños de sus familias marzo fue también
el mes en el que hubo más migrantes
detenidos en la frontera en 20 años los
agentes fronterizos interceptaron a más
de 172.000 personas indocumentadas en la
frontera con méxico esto supone un
aumento del 76 por ciento desde febrero
de este año las personas adultas son por
lo general deportadas sólo en marzo a
103 1800 les fue negada la entrada a
territorio estadounidense